مساء الخير ، صبرك
يستحق الثناء ،
علمنا أن هذا سيحدث بشكل خاطئ ، لكن من كان
يعلم أننا
سنذهب ربما صباح الغد وربما
لفترة أطول
ولكن يبدو أننا نشعر بالرضا عن المكان الذي
نحن فيه حقًا
[تصفيق]
أنا هنا لأخبرك  الليلة نعتقد
أننا على الطريق الصحيح للفوز في هذه الانتخابات
التي عرفناها بسبب
التصويت المبكر غير المسبوق في التصويت بالبريد
الذي سيستغرق بعض الوقت ،
وعلينا التحلي بالصبر
حتى أه العمل الجاد في فرز
الأصوات  تم الانتهاء من التصويت
ولن ينتهي الأمر حتى يتم احتساب كل صوت
يتم احتساب كل بطاقة اقتراع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ولكننا نشعر
بالرضا عن مكاننا
الذي نعتقد أن إحدى الشبكات
قد اقترحت  لقد فزنا بالفعل بأريزونا ، لكننا
واثقون من
أن أريزونا هي تحول ، لقد أطلقنا عليها
للتو من ولاية مينيسوتا
وما زلنا نلعب في جورجيا
على الرغم من
أن هذا ليس ما
كنا نتوقعه ونشعر بالرضا عن
ولاية ويسكونسن وميشيغان
وبواسطة  الطريقة التي ستستغرق وقتًا
للمشاركة  فيما يتعلق بالأصوات التي
سنفوز بها في ولاية بنسلفانيا ، سأتحدث إلى الناس في
مقاطعة فيلي أليغيني سكرانتون
ويشجعهم حقًا
الإقبال وما يرونه ،
كما تعلمون ، يمكننا معرفة النتائج في
وقت مبكر من صباح الغد  لكن قد
يستغرق الأمر وقتًا أطول قليلاً كما قلت طوال
الوقت ،
إنه ليس مكاني أو مكان دونالد
ترامب لإعلان من فاز في هذه الانتخابات
هذا قرار الشعب الأمريكي
لكنني متفائل بشأن هذه
النتيجة وأريد أن أشكر الجميع  منكم الذين
خرجوا وصوتوا في هذه الانتخابات
وبالمناسبة كريس كونز والديمقراطيون ،
تهانينا هنا في ديلاوير
[تصفيق] ،
مرحبًا جون ، أنت الحاكم ، نعم مثل
كل
رجل الفريق الذي قمت بعمل رائع ، أنا
ممتن
للعاملين في الاستطلاع إلى المتطوعين
لدينا ،
كل من شارك في هذه
العملية
الديمقراطية وأنا ممتن لجميع مؤيدي
هنا في ديلاوير وفي جميع أنحاء
البلاد ،
شكرًا لكم ، شكرًا لكم والناس الذين
سمعتموني أقول ذلك من قبل  في كل مرة
أخرج فيها من منزل جدي في
سكرانتون ، صرخ جوي
احتفظ بالإيمان وجدتي
عندما تضحك ، أوه ، لا جوي نشرها ،
حافظ على الإيمان يا رفاق ، سنربح هذا ،
شكرًا لك ، شكرًا لك ، شكرًا لك